hey guys this is nessa founder thick
hair and i'm david griffin your resident
comic book and video game guru and this
is our review of alfonso cuarón's
gravity long-awaited gravity which
actually me and David saw almost a year
ago and I'm pretty sure we shot a review
for it but I came this but I can't find
it right I got my hard drive like
somewhere we couldn't talk about it yeah
so yeah we couldn't talk about it but we
did shoot a review and then now we're
just shooting a new one cuz I can't find
the right special effects weren't even
finished when we saw it so yeah yeah but
I think in general most of it was
intentions of what the story was and
what the themes were and yeah I had to
say I thought it was pretty fantastic I
don't know if I love the movie but I
think I really really like it there are
moments that I do love and I think it's
a great experience that's visually
stunning technically and achievement
what do you think and i agree i think
i've been trying two phrases people like
because everybody like you know work
everywhere buddies talking about how
BIG's movies you guys do and I and every
time I hear that I almost want to tell
everybody like will kind of hold your
expectations in check because while the
film is it's awesome it's this visual
spectacular feast but it's not about
silly world building or story sound like
a big huge story it's very personal for
how much spectacles going on i mean it's
i would say it's like castaway in space
just Tom Hanks castaway movie in space
that's really small really intimate it's
good but it is it kind of reminds you
like why we go to the movie theaters you
know there's you see looks in these
indie films and stuff you gotta pay
money to go see you know it's like like
wait why am i spending fifteen sixteen
dollars to go see this but like this
movie something like you want to see the
3d if you have my metro sometime yeah a
lot i don't know doble at most theaters
like go see it the nicest theater you
can see it's worth it yeah i think it's
one of those movies like Avatar they've
created a visual yeah that's right where
Creek creates an immersive experience
and you feel like you're in space right
you like and that's the whole purpose if
you know this isn't a spoiler but like
the style of it there's a lot of long
take especially the first one it's like
a 22-minute untuk take right obviously
there's tricks there that yeah you know
they didn't really run it for 22 minutes
but but the reason why they do that is
to give that sense that you
are in space with them because you're
not gonna get you know we start cutting
in space too much then you start to feel
like well there's a move you feel a
camera yeah I feel like okay this is a
movie and and you don't feel like you're
floating there but you know when you're
watching I'm sure you felt it the same
way like you felt like you were yeah
even with them yeah I mean even when we
saw it like again like eight nine months
ago ever long it was I mean for the
visuals ruin finished ice we're talking
with in the movies like man that is some
of the best space scenes I've ever seen
it that's avatar you know even in the
80s like with aliens like those are some
of the base best space footage I've seen
I was like man this is it looks so good
and I guess the way they made it was
more like almost like they were just
kind of like you know their faces and
stuff we're there ever a lot of it was
just you know special effects they did a
really good job with their special
effects looks really good and then as
far as the casting there's not many
characters in this you really just have
Sandra Bullock and George Clooney and we
had talked about in our first review
that at least I felt that like I think
Sandra Bullock did a great job with it
especially out the casting news is out
like it was supposed to be Angelina it
was supposed to be Angela Corbin they
floated it too and seen charlize theron
I think was in that mix as well I think
this is Sandra she's on a roll I mean
biggest call me the year you know I
think money-wise you know and then with
this I mean she I think if they would at
Angelina I think engine is good i think
angelina is Angelina Sandra Bullock can
kind of hide in this role and I think
she was brilliant see I think like
someone like a Charlotte I would've been
interested to see if charlize theron and
maybe Robert Downey jr. instead of
George Clooney yeah in that role but
yeah I mean that's you know that's right
no fedex right right yeah but yeah she
did a great job with him it is her movie
george clooney's the co-star but you
know he's he's not as prominent right
yeah I mean it is like I said I was
referred to a life cast wit but it's
just such a visual I mean that's what is
its so much about the visuals that I
don't see the story's bad but it's not
like don't go there expecting like this
poetic dialogue like Terran don't expect
some 15 minute conversation at a bar
like Tarantino rights I mean with just
back and forth like I mean it is more of
about the visual feeds cuz sometimes a
dialogue a little cheesy here and there
but I mean it's fine it's good it
doesn't matter because
it's about the visual storytelling that
moves that makes this movie so good well
let's wrap up our thoughts and then
we'll go into a spoiler section after
but let's wrap up our thoughts and give
it great so I'm going to give the movie
an a-minus I think it's fantastic I
think you should see it the only I guess
criticisms i have is i think even for a
movie that has very little dialogue some
of the dialogue does come off a little
cheesy sure over the top especially in
one of the sequences not that it's like
horrible writing it just it's too much
it's weird for a movie that has barely
any dialogue I think it actually needs
even less right yeah so that would be my
my criticism what about you I agree
obviously do the same thing i'll give it
an a-minus I mean visually it's just
like there's some of the best space
scenes that I've ever seen I think the
special effects the the acting you know
I mean just everything which is
top-notch I mean this is you know fonso
Kieran and his son both wrote this and
they did a great job yeah definitely a
minus yeah so definitely I definitely
recommend see the theater it's an
experience so let's get into the spoiler
stuff where we're going to actually talk
about what happens in the movie and and
what we thought so yeah so when I was
talk about the criticism the I didn't
like the dialogue that that uh Sandra
Bullock's character has with herself me
and she thinks she's dying in that they
in the in one of the pods yeah right it
was just a little too on the nose it was
like kind of like trying to let the
audience know this is my whole backstory
and this is how I'm feeling right now
yeah I don't think I needed that I don't
think he needed the fact that her
daughter I don't think you need that tie
to her I mean it's nice to have context
but I think there's so much danger and
suspense and stuff going on in space
when I don't think you don't really need
to know much about their personal lives
I mean I'm clearly talking about like a
little bit Texas down there like the
different places that's fine I mean but
you don't need to know all about them
like there's so much going on you feel
for them no matter maybe they could have
a dying grandmother of cancer I mean it
doesn't you don't need that extra heft
on there i don't think i don't think
it's necessary yeah well I think that's
the thing is that Alfonso Quran has an
overall theme of the movie and that's
why he has rebirth like yeah position
yeah so that's why he wanted tie in her
is her daughter it was like coping with
that death and that law so that she can
be reborn yeah you have her in the fetal
position with that umbilical cord coming
out is very blatant and obvious and then
you have several other things like even
the pod you know how it's like stuck to
the this the space station and like how
it's like supposed to be like you know
the umbilical cord Greg getting cut off
just to cut it off to break free you
have a scene where she's crying like a
baby you know and they have the baby in
the background when she lands on earth
she first crawls and then she starts
standing up like a little kid would like
kind of like her legs are wobbling and
stuff soon atmosphere going through fire
I mean yeah yeah symbolism yeah so I
think that's the main reason that that
Alfonso Quran put that in there you know
so they could have even this story was
very simple he wanted to tie that into a
larger thing and he's big on that I mean
children of men you know definitely had
some of those type of big themes you he
likes it but I mean again the story is
such a visual Matt Marvel they all that
little stuff kind of its like when
Cameron makes a great movie I mean
didn't cameras have the best
screenwriter though you were the aliens
I love alien that so many times well
some of the best lines and nails were
actually improv long exactly right yeah
so I mean it's just but visually it's
just pretty stunning yeah yeah um what
are some other stuff in this story that
you didn't care for you did really like
like it i mean i liked it i think you
know i think i like the casting I I
think the story is good I mean it's very
simple I love people seen coming through
like literally fire coming through a
tough University and coming out stronger
I like seeing that I mean all the stuff
that she has to go through I hate all
the talk of the news right now but how
scientific everything is when you watch
this movie go to the food there's
nothing that again says based on a true
story this is not yes Neil deGrasse
Tyson a he commented on like how a bunch
of the stove was scientifically I'm sure
trickery I trust these are the one of
the most of us are my smarts guys in the
world but it's like this isn't a true
story I find the car didn't set out to
make a realistic movie about astronaut
she's making a drama
drama so I hope when you see it like
don't get too scientific with it just
enjoy it for what it is and then the
music I thought the music was fantastic
and fit is very suspenseful and they
amped it up when things were like going
crazy and then they took it down you
know when things weren't so uh there was
a point in the movie but it luckily this
thing came true come true but you know
when George Clooney comes back you know
there's a point where you thinking oh my
god is really really but it ends up
being just inner owes an education it
was good care in our mind so that part I
was like okay right but at first I was
like don't be that haha no that's good
it's definitely worth saying I'm this is
a movie that is so visually impressive a
little story you know quirk society
that's really good really we're seeing
alright alright guys so let us know what
you thinking post your comments below on
the website or on our YouTube channel
that's think hero pro make sure you
subscribe to the channel please go I'm
checking us out on twitter too I will
talk to us dennis michael everybody a
ratfink hero personally i'm at griffin
de and we all saw the facebook page
that's facebook.com slash think hero
fans
you